pendant près d'un siècle c'est
l'industrie de la chaussure qui fait
tourner l'économie de montréal et bien
sûr chaque paroisse à son cordonnier
bien connu du quartier
nous sommes dans côte-des-neiges et ce
matin direction la cordonnerie du
quartier celle où j'allais quand j'étais
tout petit
[Musique]
saleh bonjour merci de nous avoir écrit
m merci beaucoup
les gens ne vont plus la cordonnerie où
il ya plus de cordonnier c'est quoi le
problème à l'origine c'est très dur
trouver un employé les gens sont
vieillissants ceux qui sont de la relève
c'est de père en fils
et puis il n'y a plus beaucoup de fils
aujourd'hui et il n'y a plus beaucoup de
québécois parce que la plupart des
cordonnerie aujourd'hui c'est diverses
origines
on n'enseigne plus la cordonnerie non
exactement où on en 5 plus on nous a dit
que c'était un manque
il ya un manque de d'élèves et si vous
voulez avoir un employé demain matin
parce que vous êtes fait des heures de
foule sous les employés il y en a pas
aussi en auriez vous le former deux
rôles exactement cessé de 0,6 un peu
difficile parce que moi je suis seul
soit que je prends une personne comme
associés où je vend l'entreprise tout
simplement
donc ça se peut vous faire mieux qu'aux
des neiges perdre son cordonnier qui
était là depuis toujours
ah oui c'est ce par quoi tout est
possible
direction plateau mont royal sur
l'avenue papineau
on a pignon sur rue depuis depuis 1987
alors si je serai encore compter je
pense à 4 1 2 1 mais il ya encore des
gens qui croient que c'est important où
ses personnages des séries la durée de
vie nos objets des défunts réparer ou
est ce qu'on trouve des gens qualifiés
pour ça ah ça c'est le bout qui est pas
simple en effet au simple parce que le
nombre de diplômés encore donnerait au
québec a drastiquement baissé au fil des
années jusqu'à ne faire aucun finissants
de 2004 à 2010 l'année suivante faute de
candidats le programme est abolie devant
la hausse de la demande bien je resterai
la disponibilité du service est un peu
léger mais heureusement qu'ils auront
besoin de demandes complexes qu'ils
voudraient c'est pour dans 2 jours ben
si j'avais quatre employés partagent
près d'un lac huppé mais là je pourrai
pas va falloir considérer avec matt
forces supplémentaires
[Musique]
dernier arrêt tony pappas une entreprise
familiale en affaires depuis 1900 c'est
la mort dans l'âme qu'on a dû fermer la
cordonnerie
c'est terminé une page d'histoire qui se
tourne
c'est une grande page d'histoire surtout
ici maintenant c'était tout le sens 18
ans qu'on faisait les travaux de
cordonnerie pourquoi principalement la
main d'oeuvre un manque de main d'oeuvre
simplement on chercher leurs élèves
sérieusement depuis environ cinq ans on
était même allé à l'étranger et ou qu'on
devait passer dans le dédale des délais
mettra-t-il très long et quand même
assez coûteux le travail est toujours là
les gens venaient porter des chaussures
des bottes il y avait une demande
quand il ya une demande encore pour ça
ou les gens jettent quand c'est fini
nous on avait une très forte demande
nous on était six séjours semaines on
avait une équipe qui roulait sur cinq
jours ou semaines on était cinq donc
aucun programme facile pour vous qui
existent pour par exemple faire venir
des jeunes ici les former ça existe pas
ici n'est pas ma connaissance qui
existent l'école des métiers du cuir
noir ça c'est surtout pour la création
pour ceux qui veulent créer qui veulent
se lancer dans la production de
chaussures ou de d'articles de cuir mais
comme la réparation comme tel il n'y a
plus rien qui existent malheureusement
et là c'est une avalanche de cordonnerie
qui ferme c'est parce que la faim moi il
y en a peut-être qui vont rester on
l'espère mais c'est la fin d'une époque
je suis de la génération et je suis
toujours comme le jambon dans la salle
which je vous dirai dans la relève
comme des gens de mon âge on pouvait les
compter sur les doigts de notes mais
c'est pas ça souvent ces machines là
silencieuse comme ça ça fait depuis fin
mai qu'on a qu'on a cessé nos activités
depuis ce temps là c'est silencieux
l'odeur aussi souvent les gens quand ils
rentraient percevant une odeur de colle
de cuir de solvants tranquillement ses
odeurs love on disparaît c'est beaucoup
merci
[Musique]